♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE ADMINISTRATION
TODAY ISSUED A STRONG
CONDEMNATION OF A MAJOR FOREIGN
POWER THAT ROUTINELY HACKS
AMERICAN INFRASTRUCTURE, STEALS
NATIONAL SECRETS, TECHNOLOGY,
PERSONAL INFORMATION, AND HUGE
QUANTITIES BEAR THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI CALL THIS COUNTRY THE
GREATEST LONG-TERM THREAT TO
AMERICA'S WELL-BEING.
RUSSIA -- SORRY, CHINA --
MISREAD THAT.
MORE THAN TWO DECADES NOW, IT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN CHINA.
AMERICA'S GREATEST GEOPOLITICAL
RIVAL.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW THAT FROM
WATCHING TELEVISION.
EVEN THIS WEEK, WITH THE NEW
NEWS ABOUT CHINA, THERE IS ONLY
ONE FOREIGN POWER ON THE RADAR
CONSIDERED A THREAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> THE RUSSIANS EXPLOITED A
MASSIVE BACK DOOR INTO THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
MOSCOW'S ATTACK ON AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
>> THE WORK BY RUSSIAN AGENTS TO
TRY TO DESTABILIZE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
>> EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> THE LONG-TERM DAMAGE IS GOING
TO WEAKEN OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
SILENT AND SEEMINGLY OKAY WITH
THIS KIND OF ATTACK IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE ARE SO
STUPID, IT IS AMAZING THEY ARE
EMPLOYED.
DIRECTOR OF THE SENATE FOR
CHINESE STRATEGY, AUTHOR OF "100
YEAR MARATHON," A STRATEGY NO
LONGER SECRET THANKS TO HIS BOO
BOOK.
MICHAEL PILLSBURY JOINS US
TONIGHT FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A CONFIRMATION,
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY, BUT WE
MAY HAVE KNOWN.
BUT STILL STRIKING.
>> ONLY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
CALLED CHINA OUR MAIN ARRIVAL,
AND SPECIFICALLY SAID IT THEIR
GOAL IS TO REPLACE US AS THE
GLOBAL SUPERPOWER, THAT IS THE
SUBTITLE OF MY BOOK.
IT IS NOT JUST GOOD NEWS FOR ME,
IT SHOWS THE RECOGNITION OF THE
PROBLEM OF CHINA, NOW GETTING
QUITE WIDESPREAD.
>> Tucker: GIVE US THE SCALE
OF THE HACKING EFFORTS BY THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBER
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBEO
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBEY
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBEF
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBER
>> THEY ARE MARBLE NUMBE.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF
TECHNIQUES, SOME REVEALED TODAY.
THERE IS THIS WONDERFUL TERM I
HOPE YOU WILL START USING CALLED
"STONE PANDA," THE CODE NAME FOR
THE CHINESE UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE A
RESTAURANT.
>> ACCORDING TO THE DECLASSIFIED
MATERIAL, IT SEEMS TO GO BACK 12
YEARS, IT SEEMS TO FOCUS ON
AMERICAN COMPANIES.
THE DATA THEY STOLE COULD HELP
WITH BUSINESS NEGOTIATIONS WITH
COMPANIES.
THEY ALSO GET TRADE SECRETS.
IT IS MASSIVE, AND IT SEEMS TO
BE FOCUSED ON THE HIGH-END
TECHNOLOGY SECTORS THAT CHINA
WOULD NEED TO DOMINATE BY 2030
OR 2035 TO BE THE WORLD LEADER.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE TO
STEAL THEIR WAY TO GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP, LET'S PUT IT THAT
WAY, MORE POLITE THAN
DOMINATION.
THE FBI IS BLOWING THE WHISTLE
TODAY, ALONG WITH THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THERE HAS BEEN
A BIG LEAK THAT STEVE MNUCHIN
AND THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT ARE
GOING TO OFFER SANCTIONS TODAY
AS PUNITIVE FOR THESE THINGS,
DOJ AND FBI ARE FIGHTING.
FOR SOME REASON, THE LAST LAST
MINUTE, TREASURY PULLED OUT.
THEY ARE PUTTING THE SANCTIONS
FORWARD.
THIS LEAK SHOWS DISSENT INSIDE
THE TRUMP TEAM, AND CHINESE HAVE
A STRATEGY THAT VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE SPOKE ABOUT BACK IN
OCTOBER, THAT THEY WANT TO
DIVIDE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS GOOD NEWS, IT RAISES
PUBLIC AWARENESS FOR WHAT CHINA
IS UP TO.
THERE WERE NO ACTUAL SANCTIONS
ANNOUNCED, OTHER THAN THE
INDICTMENT OF THE TWO CHINESE
HACKERS, OUT OF POSSIBLE 10,000,